I became a singer-songwriter, I guess it was in high school.
I had a great music teacher in high school, and she kind of encouraged me...
...to start taking guitar lessons and piano lessons and start to write songs.
We kind of like the spontaneity of life that being in a band, you get to be in.
Everything about Nashville, I love.
There's something about Nashville that just, I don't know,...
...it just feels good to people.
It just inspires more creativity.
I could just not handle a nine-to-five desk job.
Every day for me is totally different.
It's kind of a daily adventure.
You never know what your schedule looks like.
Our day just changes each day.
Yeah!